[Musique]
messieurs bonjour bonjour nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle sinkerview présentez-vous
dataagule alors qui a tiré le premier
siège c'est moi alors comment tu
t'appelles alors c'est
je suis l'enquêteur et co-auteur de
cette histoire donc je suis celui qui ne
parle pas et qui ne tourne pas c'est
tout c'est déjà pas mal [__] il y a du
taf passe la parole à ton voisin de
droite merci bien Julien g je suis
co-auteur concepteur de dat taagule et
voilà donc moi j'écris plutôt j'enquête
un peu et je parle un peu aussi moi je
suis Henri Je suis concepteur avec
Julien du format dataagule et je le
réalise voilà alors pourquoi réaliser
datagule Henri bah parce que du coup
comme j'ai l'ai un peu conçu j'ai j'ai
voulu le réaliser et pour le pogon aussi
non pas du tout combien ça coûte un dat
Guu à faire alors il y a eu plusieurs
alors attends est-ce que combien ça
coûte en vrai ou combien ça coûte
comment c'est payer le temps le temps
qu'on y passe en jour ou profitez-en
pour négocier vos salaires les gars ou
non non en fait c'est on va pas rentrer
dans les détails de chiffres qui sont en
plus vraiment on n' pas grand chose à
cacher puisque c'est serait plutôt en
notre faveur c'est on est payé TR an de
ça de ce que nous serions payés pour
d'autres formats plus traditionnels plus
conventionnel euh mais c'était pas une
affaire d'argent cette ce ce ce
programme c'est une affaire de militant
c'est en enfin c'est une affaire de
conviction d'envie et de conviction
avant tout euh la la l'origine du désir
de de ce format et de ce format là où on
l'a diffusé à savoir YouTube là où le
service public était assez peu présent
euh correspondait au désir effectivement
de toucher les gens qui ne n'avait pas
accès à un certain nombre d'informations
et nous on pouvait essayer de leur
permettre d'y accéder avec un ton et une
forme leur permettant de de d'être
attiré par cette par cette ces
informations est-ce que tu penses que
est-ce que tu penses que dataag joue un
rôle important pour contrer les fake
news ce serait prétentieux de le dire
ainsi mais on aimerait y contribuer
voilà en ettre je sais pas si c'est les
fake news en fait qui nous intéressent
je pense plutôt que enfin en tout cas le
notre ce qu'on a en frontal dans la
colonne à droite dans les
recommandations c'est plutôt les alin
Soral les dieux donnés laosphère donc
plutôt le complot que les fake news ce
qui sont deux choses différentes quand
même structurellement on a beaucoup de
gens en fait qui nous regardent beaucoup
de d'usagers de YouTube qui nous
regardent d'internautes et dont on est
en fait l'une des seules sources
alternatives dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire alternative à la
fachosphère et à des personnes qui leur
mettent dans le crâne une certaine
vision du monde c'est quoi la fchosphère
la fchosphère c'est tout le tout le tout
le le système et le réseau qui s'est
formé autour d'une
droite qui ne dit pas son nom qui dit
pas son nom en fait mais c'est en gros
ça correspond à l'époque où Alain Soral
a connecté Marine Lepen avec Dieu donné
et avec les ogres et toute cette galaxie
là c'était il y a près de 10 ans et à
l'époque on n a pas trop prêté attention
sauf qu'en fait ils sont développés sur
Youtube et c'est leur terrain et aller
sur leur terrain pour dire autre chose
sur les sujets que parfois ils traitent
eux même et qui sont parfois les seuls à
traiter comme le France CFA quand on a
fait une vidéo sur le France CFA les
seules autres vidéos c'était Dieu donné
et en l'occurrence dans les comments un
tiers des commenes c'était ah Dieu donné
on a parlé donc moi enfin et on partage
cet objectif là en frontal on a ça c'est
aussi donner une alternative à ce qu'il
croit être une alternative à
l'information mainstream le pluralisme
ouais le pluralisme et puis l'occasion
aussi de porter une une exigence
factuelle là où ils n'ont qu'une
exigence en terme de de discours et de
forme qui vont va les porter
naturellement vers des gens qui parlent
très bien mais qui disent quand même
beaucoup de conneries Julien toi ton
avis j non mais moi je je vais revenir
sur un des trucs que tu as dit c'est
c'est le une de tes questions le
militantisme et ça rebondit sur le
pluralisme ce qui est aussi intéressant
dans l'énergie qui a qui a porté dat
taagule jusqu'ici depuis 3 ans c'est
aussi le pluralisme et la diversité à
l'intérieur de ces trois personnesl et
c'est-à-dire que quand Henry répond oui
c'est une forme de militantisme c'est
une forme d'engagement de conviction
c'est vrai mais on n pas les mêmes alors
on n'est pas aux opposés pas tout à fait
les mêmes il y a desb toujours mais il y
a toujours il y a il y a des convictions
c'est certain et et et c'est vraiment ça
qui est passionnant dans ce travail là
c'est qu'il y a des convictions qui sont
diversifier ce qui fait une partie de la
richesse du travail c'est que si on
schématise Sylvain par exemple va faire
le gros de l'enquête data aller chercher
le plus la masse la plus importante des
données 70 80 % moi je vais faire le
reste 30 20 30 % mais je vais pas aller
chercher les mêmes choses parce que j'ai
pas la même sensibilité sur les mêmes
sujets sur le sujet et souvent on on
sait pas qu'on s'écharpe mais on est on
n'est pas d'accord on a eu on a eu le
cas hier on n' pas la même vision d'un
sujet on n pas les même questionnement
on n pas mais ça nous bloque jamais en
fait c'estd que comment comment vous
faites pour avoir un
consensus on cherche pas forcément
consensus on cherche pas le consensus on
on cherche à à comprendre le sujet en
fait c'estàd que c'est là que c'est
intéressant on cherche pas à imposer une
vision euh sur ce que devrait être euh
tel sujet qu'on va traiter là en
l'occurrence c'est un sujet qui a trait
aux inégalités des sexes qu'on est en
train de travailler euh et gros gros
scoup voilà
euh mais la question c'est pas de
trouver la vérité sur ce sujet-là mais
c'est de partager des questionnements et
donc on se pose pas les mêmes questions
syvin et moi et et les réponses qu'on
qu'on voit traverser dans les datas
qu'on croise et dans les faits qu'on
croise nous raconte pas exactement la
même chose et on partage nos
interrogations et moi je dis bah voilà
j'ai compris ça sy me dit non moi je
comprends plutôt ça et du coup on
reprend les faits on remouline et dans
la discussion on en arrive à se dire ah
ok on a voilà ça y est on a fini par
comprendre la même chose la même
question on porte la même question final
et la mise en forme et la mise en forme
rend compte de cette diversité
finalement c'est pas un objet dogmatique
dat taagule 12 minutes aujourd'hui 15
minutes précédemment c'est un objet
pluriel foisonnant riche où on peut où
l'internaut pourra et nous nous le
faisons déjà en amont puiser des pistes
de réflexion de débat mais au-delà de ça
le LEF débat les débats ne sont pas
stériles dans le sens où il y a l'un des
aboutissements c'est la production du
programme mais l'un des autres
aboutissements c'est aussi que on
cherche pas le consensus dans dans le
sens où on finit pas d'accord sur le
même point par contre on change on
révise nos opinions on progresse on
essae de de enfin à la lumière de ça moi
j'ai changé sur ma vision de plein de
trucs
comme bah moi bosser pour datagu et
regarder certaines vérités factuelles et
et documenter sur la viande
principalement d'ailleurs pas tellement
du côté de la souffrance animale mais
plutôt du côté de l'effet sur le climat
euh sur l'eau sur l'enjeu également
économique les déséquilibres nord- sudud
que ça impose la déforestation bah je
suis devenu végétarien et il y a plein
de trucs comme ça juste pour finir
là-dessus qui qui nous même sur des tout
petits trucs mais Julien et moi voilà
effectivement on n'est pas dans cette
idée d'imposer notre idée à l'autre on
va être dans un débat on va s'alimenter
de ce qu'on a comme donnée mais après on
va arriver à un point où finalement
Julien a une
idée nourrie de ça de de notre de notre
débat et moi aussi et on a tous les deux
avancé parce que on est ni l'un ni
l'autre dogmatique et c'est en ça
qu'effectivement la notion de
militantisme elle se place plutôt au
niveau de la façon qu'on a de
communiquer ce qu'on veut faire passer
comme ça la façon veut faire passer
plutôt que sur l'idée préétablie d'un
sujet beaucoup dejet changé c'est une
intelligence collaborative horizontale
alors juste une chose très importante
mais ça ça ça prolonge que tu viens
d'amorcer c'estd que datagle c'est un
objet qui est en mouvement permanent il
est en mouvement dans sa gestation dans
sa dans sa dans mise en forme et puis
est en mouvement une fois qu'il est mise
en ligne puisque il se il génère c'est
pas une vidéo qui qui passe une fois
pour tout et basta et on passe à autre
chose il génère mécaniquement des
commentaires il est discuté des
commentaires qu'on lit donc il commence
il se prolonge dans ta gueule c'est pas
encore une fois qu'une vidéo c'est une
vidéo des sources dans les métadonnées
et les commentaires et c'est l'ensemble
c'est ces trois éléments qui qui qui
créent l' en parlant des sources euh je
vous pose la question à vous trois
comment vous allez chercher vos chiffres
comment vous expertisez vos sources
comment vous triangulez vos sources
quand il y a des sources qui sont euh on
va dire en opposition frontale comment
vous faites pour avoir un juge de paix
sur ces sources là bah pour le coup ça a
beaucoup évolué aussi j'ai énormément
appris dans cet exercice là et on essaie
au maximum en fait de se baser sur des
critères de fiabilité internes aux
sources j'ai appris avec Julien à bah
savoir quelle étéit la fiabilité d'une
source scientifique d'une étude
scientifique et plus avant en fait plus
on va profondément là-dedans et l'idée
que il y ait des sources qui s'opposent
de manière frontale et qui disent
absolument pas la même chose en fait
c'est une idée qui est basé sur le fait
généralement que tu vas pas assez
profond quand tu vas assez profondément
dans la formation de la source dans la
production de la donnée ou d'une étude
scientifique tu te rends compte que il y
a jamais deux fois le même protocole il
y a jamais deux fois la même population
il y a jamais deux fois la même question
qui est posée donc il y a jamais deux
sondages qui s'opposent frontalement
parce qu'ils sont jamais fait dans les
mêmes conditions donc en soit c'est dans
ce questionnement et je pense que la
différence par par rapport à à certaines
visions où on peut se retrouver avec de
sources qui se contredisent c'est que
c'est la profondeur c'est qu'on essaie
toujours d'aller bah à la source de la
source de la source et c'est on est
Julien et moi et Henry des des des fils
intellectuels aussi de l'intertexualité
d'Internet de de l'hypertexte donc on
passe notre temps à remonter d'une
source à la source de la source à la
source de la source et ça peut nous
amener très très très loin mais dans des
dans des mindfuck de malad où on passe
une demi-journée à chercher ce [__] de
chiffre qui peut nous confirmer que
effectivement il y a plus de filles qui
échouent parce qu'elles sont moins sûr
d'ell dans le classement PISA peut-être
qu'ils va l'infirmer après et onou
peutêtre qu' se retrouver avec un truc
qui contredit mais il faut l'assumer le
fact checking et est-ce que vous avez
déjà été fact checké d'une façon
violente par l'Internet récemment il y a
eu un petit un
petit une petite tension révélée amorcé
par alors je sais plus quel
blogque après relayé par fa des
nom biologie ce qui nous embêté qu'on a
bien ce qu'il fait globalement enfin
quelqu'un d'intéressant qui l'a relayé
en prenant un fait COS pour ce fa
checking cétait pas c'était pas du fact
checking c'était plus reproche de
d'utilisation de biais lesffet en
euxmême nétait pas de B narratif et
effectivement dans C é il y avait des
bien narratifs et je reviens là-dessus
parce que ça prolonge un peu ce on a
parlé précédemment c'est que
indépendamment de cette enquête très
précise très fouillé obsessionnel qui
qui s'amorce d'ailleurs en amont moi de
ma ma de de de mon intervention sur le
sujet même si on parle des sujets en
amont au tout début bien sûr mais après
je laisse travailler parce que ils font
un travail que je ne sais pas faire et
ils le font remarquablement mais je vois
l'obsession avec lequelle ils le font ce
travail bi après quand je commence à
recevoir les informations et donner des
textes je je vois naître les lignes de
force ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
lignes de force c'est du potiisme en
fait c'est c'est c'est deimpressionnisme
tous ces petits points justusqu'àpr
finissent par faire naître effectivement
des des tensions des des des gestes
narratifs ou qu'on pourrait appeler des
billets effectivement il y a des
facilités parfois mais ou des facilités
ou des ou des des éléments de narration
presque mais qui n'ont qui ne se
justifie que parce que encore une fois
c'est un datagu ne s'intterrom pas au
moment où il est diffusé parce qu'il
propose d'être un objet qui se discute
qui
s'interroge et qui permet de se nourrir
d'autres sources et de les réinterpréter
à son tour et du coup ce billet là
on est prêt à l'assumer je pense que sur
celui-ci on l'urait assumé différemment
si non non puis alors pour revenir sur
cette question là on a des des voilà on
a des effectivement des fact check sur
les données et notre démarche de mettre
les données en ligne elle part de ça
c'estàdire allons-y questionnons
transpar voilà on a aucun problème avec
ça on a aucun problème avec ça pour une
raison très simple c'est qu'on est les
premiers à penser que rien n'est
objectif et surtout pas les données et
ça c'est un point essentiel et c'est un
glissement euh assez terrible qui est en
train d'exister aujourd'hui c'est de se
dire le la nouvelle vérité c'est les
données ce qui est une absurdité totale
les données sont subjectives parce
qu'elles sont elles doivent être
contextualisées elles ont un contexte
d'émission elles ont un contexte de
création c'est-à-dire quand un set de
données est cré il a un contexte de
création et quand quelqu'un se sert de
ce set de données pour raconter quelque
chose ça rajoute un prisme de lecture
donc voilà c'est pas pour autant qu'il y
a manipulation faut bien dissocier les
choses à partir d'un moment où voilà si
moi je raconte quelque chose que j'ai
vécu je vais raconter nécessairement
avec ma subjectivité je t'ouvre une
parenthèse Palen ti Palen tire ça te
parle non comme ça non un agrégateur de
données pas du tout non on en reviendra
je ferme la parenthèse d'accord je me
suis fait j'ai un truc dans dans le
cerveau maintenant c'est pasen tir euh
donc du coup je reviens à ce truccl sur
sur le les potentiels Billis sur ce sur
cette épisode sur les industries
pharmaceutiques qui est un épisode que
nous-même on a après l'avoir mis en
ligne on s'est dit c'est pas le meilleur
voilà il il y a des trucs qui sont
fragiles et tout mais ça fait partie de
l'exercice on a fait 70 épisodes oui il
y en a qui sont plus fragiles que
d'autres il y a pas de problème avec ça
aussi les conditions de production du
datagu lui-même d' on a travaillé sur un
la constitution d'un bouquin datagu et
quand on a choisi parmi des tagueules
qu'on voulait garder on n' pas voulu
garder celui-là exactement pour ces
raisons là avant même qu'on nous dise
quoi que ce soit dessus mais nous-même
de se dire celui-là il est voilà il est
il manque de nuance en fait par qu'on on
aime la nuance dans ta gueule et
celui-là peut-être qu'il manque un peu
de nuance justement voilà et et c'est et
c'est pas notre voilà après ce qui nous
a été reproché là-dessus c'est pas tant
des reproches sur les faits alors
évidemment la personne je m'excuse j'ai
oublié son nom mais qui qui a écrit ça
va dire si si c'est bien des fait non
c'est effectivement des bi narratifs qui
sont des qui sont décriés c'estàd que
tout le propos était de dire bon alors
les faits sont justes mais il y a des
bien il y a des bi dans la manière de
les présenter alors finalement ce qui
est dit c'est quand même un peu vrai
mais au final il y a quand même des Biss
ok d'accord donc à un moment donné on
fait quoi c'est vrai c'est faux c'est il
y a un truc faut il a il y a il y a
voilà nous moi il y a un truc à un
moment donné où je dis on peut ouvrir un
peu les et c'est là que je remets la
subjectivité un peu au milieu du truc je
reprends la parole vous bossez
maintenant avec France Télévision c'est
ça on a toujoursou toujours est-ce que
on vous a fait sentir des limites sur
les les sujets j jamais
jamaisanim jamais c'est nous quions des
listes de sujets donc et puis on discute
aussi B parce que bien sûr chaque
épisode est montré à un responsable de
français tvision alors c'est un petit un
petit petite parenthèse historique quand
même parce que ça il le mérite le
programme a été initié par par les
nouvelles écritur de France Télévision
en 2014 qui était dirigé à l'époque par
Boris rison et c'est Renault aliler qui
a été assez moteur dans le fait que ce
programme existe sans eux il y aurait
pas d'agul ou qu'on l'a fait vraiment
avec eux dès le départ et avec une une
grande pertinence de Laur part qui est
plutôt rare effectivement qui éit
considéré que cet objet exister à
condition qu'on soit autonome et et ça
se passe même la limite à l'inverse
c'estd qu'il y a des sujets qui nous ont
été proposés par France Télévision qu'on
n pas pris
lesquels honnêtement j'ai plus en tête
mais euh Mo si mais bon ah bah si tu
t'en rappelles non mais pour le coup
voilà on est et en fait on voyait
derrière ça pour enfin c'est une
interprétation que j'ai mais il y avait
une espèce de de de de qui est très
classique en
fait c'est un truc très très journaliste
malheureusement dans le mauvais sens du
terme aussi un bon sens du terme c'était
on pense que la communauté attend ça or
il se trouve que s'il y a bien un truc
qu'on a appris et surtout dans la
dernière dans la dernière commande là
sur la dernière saison la dernière
fournée pr aussi c'est que le la
surprise est le meilleur vecteur
d'intérêt chez chez No dans notre
communauté typiquement l'épisode sur
l'édition scientifique il y avait
d'énormes doutes sur pas forcément la
pertinence par la pertin éditorial était
là on avait des éléments pour argumenter
mais est-ce que ça va marcher est-ce que
ça va pas être un peu microcosmique ça a
été le meilleur démarrage de l'histoire
de datagule c'est QFD donc il a un
moment où alors certes il y a une comité
derrière il y a une communé derrière
mais il y avait aussi une surprise à
savoir waouh c'est c'est quoi cette
histoire ce rendement à 35 % c'est
entreprises qu'on connait pas et qui ont
la haute main sur la recherche et du
coup finalement on se retrouve nous avec
une exigence qui est énorme vis-à-vis de
nous-même mais aussi la volonté et en
cela c'est militant temps de parler de
sujets chiants et c'est clairement enfin
moi dans des rédactions on m'a souvent
reproché ça de proposer des sujets
chiants et d' ta gueule c'est quand même
beaucoup de sujets qui sont considérés
par plein comme chiant parce qu'on ne
parle pas des maîtresses dans François
Hollande ou bien la couleur du slip de
leur voquier quelle quelle
rédaction bah moi quand j'étais chez
Marianne régulièrement on m'a dit que
j'avais des sujets qui étaient chiants
et même des fois on a eu des prises de
tête avec OVNI des collègues qui me
disaient que j'avais des sujets
chiantsgal de c'était des sujets chiants
tu vois pour revenir précisément faut
revenir à à ta question sur notre
rapport avec France Télévision France
Télévision reste c'est une un groupe de
audiovisuel service public et
majoritairement le seul le seul rapport
de force que nous pourrions avoir avec
eux et queon a eu au tout début en tout
cas c'était de dire pas de censure pas
de mais quel est votre cible parler à
une cible c'est un réflexe g télé il y a
une cible effectivement on sait qu'à
telle heure à tel endroit sur telle
chaîne on a plôt par plutôt euh euh au
aux jeunes femmes ou aux aux hommes plus
âgés ou et ce ce ce ce cette logique de
cible on l' très tôt euh euh désamorcé
puisque il était facile de dire et on
l'a dit on disait sincèrement où il y a
pas les datas dessus tatouage pourquoi
pas très beau sujet mais on a pas de
Data dessus donc effectivement le
recours au data nous permettait et nous
a permis très sincèrement hein ça en
sens que ce soit une une fausse raison
euh de de d'imposer des sujets qui était
tout à la fois pertinent d'un point de
vue purement éditorial mais également
traitable sous l'angle qui éit le l'ôre
savoir a-t-il des données ou non pour en
parler comment vous mettez ça en image
quel est quels sont vos vos
inspiration
alorspiration un programme qui qui était
diffusé sur la chaîne de télé ABC
télépuique
australienne voilà qui s'appelle The
Beast F à l'intérieur d'un programme
plus gros qui c'était qui s'appelait the
hungry Beast et donc Boris rason est
venu quand il a commencé à échanger avec
Henry puis après avec
moi Renault aussi sont venus avec cette
référence là en disant voilà on aime
bien ce truccl là qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez c'est du Motion Design il y a des
choses qu'on retrouve de ta gueule il y
a une image de fin aussi voilà donc on
est on est parti de ce c'était un peu
notre point de départ quand on a
commencé à conceptualiser de ta gueule
on est parti de là et et après on a pris
la tangente pour se dire nous qu'est-ce
qu'on a envie de faire avec un programme
de motion design qui met des datas en
forme qui essaie de révéler quelque
chose à la fin et c'est comme ça qu'on
est parti sur une sorte de mécanique on
voilà l'idée était de se dire ok il y a
plein de datas partout qui sont
présentés à chaque JT dans chaque une de
canards en permanence mais à quel moment
on les correllles entre elles et on
offre une perspective on pose une
perspective qui encore une fois n'est
pas une perspective dogmatique mais qui
est une perspective de questionnement
est-ce que vous avez eu des
menaces pas encore après cette émission
probablement on attend avec impatience
d'ailleurs si vous voulez nous menacer
on vous donne le ma
de donc pas de menace parce que vous
traitez des sujets un peu touch mais non
parce que tout est publicque en fait
c'est ça qui est génial c'est que a eu
des tensions avec Frontex par exemple à
l'occasion de l'épisode sur Frontex oui
oui il y a eu des retours mais là il
faut il faut il faut expliquer Frontex
Frontex c'est l'agence européenne qui
s'occupe de surveill frtières qui conne
la surveillance des frontières qui pas
exemple de tout reproche dans la crise
dans les milliers dizaines de milliers
de morts aux frontières de
l'Europe c'est un sujet qu'on a abordé
la 2è prière deè saison je ne sais plus
de ta guule première saison de ta guule
et le Frontex est remté au cré était pas
content de ce qu'on pouvait dire on peut
les comprendre en même temps on
maintient ce que nous nous disions il
était encore en ligne et là France
Télévision a joué très joliment son rôle
c'estàd que se fontex s'est adressé à
France Télévision qui est quand même le
diffuseur et le coproducteur du
programme France Télévision c'est a fait
obstacle on n pas du tout été inquiété
donc on est vraiment accompagné par
France Télévision sur ce cas d'école par
exemple on pourrait êre on pourrait
oublier parce qu'il y a longtemps mais
quand même ils sont effectivement ils se
sont c'est important de savoir que le
diffuseur le service public
français capable de s'opposer à un
Frontex qui dit supprimer cette vidéo
tout de
suiteel non CIT pas loin et non non et
deè de non non non c'était c'était
c'était pas lo des disensions c'est pas
du tout ce qui
é c'est c'est dire combien effectivement
la mémoire est subjective voilà donc qui
a eu une réaction
effectivement de Frontex qui était trouv
ça qui trouvait ça mal venu de la part
du service public de de diffuser de
prendre en charge la diffusion d'un tel
programme après ça s'arrête là il y a
pas eu de menace de la part pas menace
mais une demande quand même de alors so
c'est une réaction diplomatique de
modifier l'objet al c'est particulier
parce que comme c'est sur le net CPN on
peut lire on peut voir ce ce ce ce
programme encore aujourd'hui et là aussi
le le les réseaux YouTube bouleverse les
usages et surprend les institutions
de ce qui a été dit et qu'on assume
toujours est encore en ligne et
accessible aujourd'hui et après c'est
peut-être aussi une des limites de
dataagule c'estàd que les datas n'étant
jamais objectives et étant dans un monde
mouvant bouge et il y a des choses qu'on
a pu faire dans certains épisodes les
plus
datés qui sont plus forcément les
constats sont plus forcément aussi
valables ou en tout cas les rapports de
force sont en train de bouger et dans 3
4 5 ans ça aura encore bougé mais
l'internaute est capable de le
comprendre il voit que la mise en ligne
date de 2004 14 il peut réaliser aussi
que un trajet a été fait depuis mais
après ce serait absurde que quelqu'un
vienne nous poursuivre parce que
fondamentalement il y a aucun aucun
terrain pour de la diffamation 90 % des
données qu'on utilise sont disponibles
voir plusalement disponibles en ligne
c'estd que ou dans des bouquins mais qui
sont dans beaucoup de biblèqu fr et du
coup on a on on a aucune exclu et des
fois on a des commentaires un peu
perplex genre mais comment on vous
autorise à dire des trucs comme ça parce
qu'il y a une espèce de fascination et
on et ce que comprennent pas certains
internautes c'est que ce qu'on fait
finalement c'est une analyse différente
et éventuellement on traite à un autre
niveau de profondeur des données qui
sont disponible le rapport plutôt que
certains journalistes qui bah dans des
injonctions extrêmement brutales et
contraintes de produire très vite vont
lire l'introduction du rapport bah moi
je me lenquis et Julien il va se taper
aussi de trois chapitres pour compléter
ce que j'ai lu et cette différence de
profondeur finalement nous amène à
trouver des trucs qui sont dans ces
rapports mais les rapports en question
on les télécharge on met les liens ils
sont accessibles et on propose même aux
internautes de venir enfin Custodio
hipsos custodies on est qui vérifie les
vérificateurs vous vous pouvez vérifier
les vérificateur on met tous les outils
pour vérifier avec même les citations
qui correspondent au truc vous pouvez
reprendre la phrase prendre le lien et
vous allez voir et vous vous allez
chercher pour retrouver le truc donc il
y a pas de il y a pas de terrain pour
qu'on nous poursuive tout ça est
public il y a un truc tout bête aussi
sur cette question là de on utilise des
choses déjà documenté parce qu'on n'est
pas dans une logique d'investigation
pure comme peuvent l'être on connaît
bien par exemple les gens de cach
investigation puisqu'ils sont produits
par première ligne etcoproducteur de d'
tagu ils ont un an d'enquête un an
d'investigation pour aller chercher de
la donnée pour sortir des choses et
cette année d'enquête leur donne une
vraie légitimité juridique si jamais
telle entreprise décide de les attaquer
en disant il y a diffamation et bah
voilà en retour les journalistes face à
un tribunal peuvent dire voilà on a
passé un an on a appelé un tel un tel un
tel et tel nous on a deux à 4 jours
d'enquête en fait donc en deux à 4 jours
d'enquête on fait pas des miracles on
est obligé de prendre des choses qui ont
déjà été sortis vérifié des jugements
qui ont été rendus on peut pas se
permettre de prendre des choses dont on
n'est pas sûr parce que si jamais une
entreprise comme Danon comme n'importe
qui qui a une grosse force de frappe
juridique
VI on on c'est très compliqué pour nous
de justifier parce que voilà on a on n
pas la on n pas la la la profondeur
derrière de dire dire voilà ça fait un
an qu'on enquête et on a appelé toute la
terre pour justifier ce truc mais on met
à jour des systèmes on fait pas de focus
sur des points particuliers qui
nécessiteraient effectivement de double
croiser les Sour et cetera qu'on a la
possibilité effectivement de de
mécaniser alors je vais reprendre la
parole je vais vous je vais vous poser
une question un peu
personnelle à force de manier toutes ces
datas à force de vous faire des
injections de connaissance à travailler
ce type de de de problématiques comme
les migrants le nombre de de cadavres en
Méditerranée ou des des sujets vraiment
hardcore comment vous vous le gérez
psychologiquement à votre échelle
personnelle comment et aussi comment vos
proches vous considèrent ou vous
perçoivent avec avec ce ce cette
conduite autistique avec l'information
cette boulémie l'information comment
vous le gérez vous faites de la
méditation vous faites quoi vous faites
du sport ouais alors ça faudrait penser
à les méditations éventuellement
conscience je pense que je pense que il
y a le le le mot boulimi est très juste
c'estàdire que il y a un truc qui nous
rapproche profondément tous les trois
c'est qu'on est d'une
exigence chacun dans notre domaine de
travail
assez excessive c'est clair donc on est
dans la on est dans la boulimie de
effectivement Sylvain fait 70 %
d'enquête me livre un doc avec 40 50 des
fois 60 pages de documents et je
pourrais me contenter de lire et de
faire le script à partir de ça rien que
ça déjà ça lui a pété les neurones ça me
ferait sauter les miens en même temps
mais je peux pas arriver à écrire
quelque chose que j'ai pas compris donc
quand il me met trois paragraphes de
citation d'un rapport je vais être
obligé d'aller lire les deux pages qui
précèdent et les trois qui suivent du
rapport pour être sûr que je comprends
ce qu'il a écrit en fait et que je
comprends les implication donc en fait
on a effectivement une vraie boulimie et
la manière dont on le gère on est
révolté très souvent on est euh touché
par plein de choses en permanence on est
en en en en en en vous faites pas trop
chier dans les dîners avec des amis si
mais ça enfin moi en tout cas on me fait
remarquer régulièrement je finis par
avoir ce biaet justement du du du
sceptique c'est-à-dire je me retrouve
dans des discussions avec par exemple
une une fille qui me dit oui mais quand
même si tu manges 500 500 calories de
boulegours c'est mieux que si tu manges
500 g de 500 calories de de croissant je
dis bah non 500 calories donc c'est la
même unité de mesure donc c'est autant
d'énergie qui est absorbé donc les deux
vont te faire grossir autant il y en a
un qui est plus sain l'autre pas c'est
un autre il est chiant en fait le truc
non mais et le fait est que je suis
devenu vraiment sceptique je suis pas
esthéticien je comprends maintenant
comment il fonctionne même si je pense
que ça se joue des fois sur d'autres
niveaux je respecte tout à fait la
démarche mais c'est vrai que du coup il
y a un truc juste très concret mais à la
fin de chaque de chaque enquête entre
guillemets même si je continue à
enquêter parallèlement à l'enquête de
Julien pour compléter je lui dis bon
écoute voilà le doc mais j'ai relevé
quelques points qu'il faut que
j'éclaircisse et les quelques points des
fois fois c'est une liste de 80 trucs et
c'est et c'est des ça va de la petite
pétouille de est-ce qu'on a l'année
exact dans la période où on a relevé
cette population et ce pourcentage
jusqu'à éclaircir la notion de marketing
féminin tu connais Monk telonius ou non
Monk non telonius oui la série la série
je sais que Henry on a une collection je
l'ai pas
regardé autiste tu es tu es un petit
syndrome monque quand même c'est
j'arrive à débrancher mais simplement
c'est vrai que ça nous obsède et par
ailleurs pour finir là-dessus il y a des
moments où il y a un peu le syndrome du
journaliste enquêteur transversal à
savoir tu regardes une pièce et là tu
vois flotter les fait que tu as relevé à
chaque fois sur plein de trucs a un
petit côté Karim matison ça peut être ça
peut être un peu obsessionnel après on a
pas les mêmes non on en fait fa faut
comprendre répondre à cette question
faut distinguer on réagit pas de la même
manière on n' pas la même fonction
majoritairement moi c'est beaucoup
facile très majoritairement même si je
participe un tout petit peu en amont au
choix des sujets au discur sur les
sujets mais très très peu en réalité moi
ma ma mon boulot c'est de formaliser le
travail d'enquête et l'écriture qui a eu
lieu précédemment donc c'est beaucoup
plus positif parce que je prends cette
matière je la manipule j'en fais quelque
chose de j'en fais un objet audiovisuel
que j'offre après à la communauté aux
internautes à ceux qui que ça intéresse
et c'est beaucoup plus facile à
supporter puisque effectivement je suis
indigné révolté touché BL évidemment
mais ma fonction permet de me permet de
de mettre cette énergie là dans l'objet
que j'offre aux autres et entre les deux
donc entre les deux tu souffr moi je
suis dans la non mais je suis dans la
compression et c'est vrai que une autre
forme de souffrance mais c'est que le le
les les 40 ou 80 pages de Sylvain je
dois en faire une page en
fait et les 40 pages de d'enquête me
passionn c'est ça qui est terrible en
fait c'est vraiment je suis j'ai j'aime
ces enquêtes j'aime ces sujets j'aime
leur complexité c'est ça qui est
horrible j'adore cette complexité du
monde qui nous entoure que ce soit sur
le sujet de la fiscalité sur le sujet de
la pauvreté sur le sujet environnemental
tout est complexe on peut pas résumer à
aucune phrase qu'on entend si souvent
sur tous les plateaux de télé où où on
essaie de résumer une baseline des
problèmes qui sont vraiment compliqués à
comprendre et il faut que j'arrive à
enfin c'est pas il faut mais je m'oblige
parce que je peux pas faire autrement à
à rendre compte de cette complexité dans
une page et et
essayer d'avoir un peu ce per
l'essentiel cette saveur là et et ça
vraiment c'est un moment très est-ce que
vous allez sur le terrain toucher vos
datas c'estàd jours est-ce que par
exemple sur le sujet des migrants ou le
sujet du cannabis ou sujet deévasion
fiscal pas dans le cadre pas dans le
cadre personnel est-ce que probablement
parfois bien s parfois vous revoyez vos
données dans la vraie vie dans la vieou
oua bien s mais c'est c'est aussi la
vraie vie he des données la vraie vie
enfin tu vois on fait un truc sur la
viande enfin après on n pas sur des
enquêtes de TER voilà on n pas sur des
enquêtes de terrain mais la vie nous
amène à recroiser ça enfin je veux dire
terin j'ai été invité comme ça à un
congrès enfin une conférence à Lampedusa
du fait de l'épisode sur les migrants et
ce qui n'était que des données
finalement c'est devenu des gens c'est
devenu des militants c'est du les gens
qui produisent les données c'est devenu
les gens qui aident les migrants et
c'est devenu l'endroit emblématique et
c'est vrai que ça fait quelque chose
quand tu vois effectivement les données
retomber sur terre et ce qui nous ce qui
nous nourrit aussi là-dedans on n pas le
temps malheureusement d'être dans
l'enquête de terrain mais on a quand
même une passe dans l'enquête où on va
systématiquement chercher du côté des
écrits de sociologie et cette pass là
elle est importante parce qu'elle nous
elle nous rapporte ce terrain là
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser les
sociologues sont pas des gens qui vivent
enfermés dans une université c'est des
gens de terrain qui vont étudier ce qui
se
passe et qui vont au plus proche et et
lire ces écrits de sociologie sur les
sujets généralement nous amène pas de
Data mais moi c'est toujours important
parce que ça m'amène justement de la
compréhension humaine et au final dataag
c'est pas un programme de Data c'est un
programme de questionnement de l'humain
en fait de comment on vit en société de
quels sont nos mécanismes de vivre
ensemble les Data nous permettent de
porter des coups de projecteur et
d'interroger ça de faire émerger des
choses mais ce qu'on questionne au fond
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fout en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment on se parle
comment on on fait du commerce comment
on on traite la terre autour de nous
comment voilà c'est c'est vraiment le le
l'envie de base de qui a derrière ça
c'est de questionner ça d'apporter
aucune réponse et surtout voilà de pas
chercher de vraiment apporter un maximum
de questions mais d'autres questions que
celles qu'on se pose habituellement
voilà d'essayer d'aller tourner un peu
le projecteur pour voir autrement
essayer de Al c'est un peu une lubie du
moment pour moi mais quand on dit on va
être 9 milliards en 2050 ok tout le
monde part tête baissée il faut faire
moins d'enfants surtout chez les pays P
il faut produire plus pour l'agriculture
parce que sinon on aura jamais assez à
manger pour tout le monde voilà et d'un
coup nous notre démarche va êre se dire
attendez attendez on produit déjà pour
12 milliards donc ça veut dire que le
problème c'est pas la production
agricole l'emprunte carbone des gens là
où il y a le plus haut taux de fécondité
c'est la plus faible donc ça veut dire
que c'est pas une question de taux de
fécondité donc ça se passe à un autre
endroit donc S se passe à un autre
endroit qu'est-ce qu'on va chercher et
cette complexité là elle est elle est
trop peu racontée et nous elle nous
passionne quand quand là on est en
période
électorale quand vous écoutez les on
fait des bons mais on fait des bons on
fait des bons on s'en VO c'était très
drôle pour le débat de la primaire
j'avais en parallèle des SMS de Julien
et de Henry qui tombait et je leur
répondais tu as vu il a dit ça mais rend
compte comment est-ce qu'il peut dire ça
sur le travail encore au en 2017 après
tout ce qui est sorti il pourrait citer
stigler ouais mais tu comprends c'est
compliqué et on avait des échanges comme
ça non mais on peut avoir un stéréotype
voilà au jour où on engiste cette
émission là maintenant au moment on se
parle on est au lendemain du débat
histoire de redonner le repèpation
temporel on est au lendemain du débat à
montvals de la primaire de la gauche
enfin du du parti socialisteun partie de
la gauche d'une partie de la gauche
d'une partie du Parti socialiste euh et
donc il s'est passé à un moment donné ce
truc qui moi m'a fait bondir où Vals sur
la question du revenu universel a dit
and la
fêes cand de la f d'Ô mais ça c'est
vraim tout ce qui me fait vomir en fait
c'estd Ré
réit et la question n'est même pas de
savoir est-ce que moi individuellement
je soutiens ou pas le revenu de base en
tout cas je me suis renseigné dessus
c'est un truc qui me questionne qui
m'interroge et ça n'est pas résumable à
ça c'est faux le revenu de base c'est
quelque chose qui cherche et ça c'est un
truc qu'on entend jamais qui cherche à
décorrler le revenu de l'emploi c'est
même pas le travail c'est de l'emploi et
ça mais si si je je t'ouvre une
parenthèse si je te dis que le revenu de
base favorise l'émergence d'une
intelligence artificielle forte alors il
faudrait que tu développes ta pensée
pour que je puisse comprendre en quoi
quels sont les mécanismes et
éventuellement discuter c'est enfin tu
me dis ça comme ça c'est une affirmation
ok faut l'étayer pour que je puisse
comprendre en quoi ça émergerait ça
aiderait à l'émergence d'une
intelligence artificielle forte est-ce
que c'est parce que ça libère du temps
de j'en sais rien en fait euh je te je
t'enverrai lien où on le mettra sur sur
nos réseaux il y a une audition au Sénat
sur ah oui ah c'est Laurent Alexandre
j'ai pas encore eu le temps d'écouter
son j'ai vu passer ça je lui envoyé sur
slack voilà on partage aussi des trucs
parce que ça fait partie d'une des
vidéos que je vais regarder parce que
elle m'a interp bon parenthèse fermé ok
on en était à à qu dire que la
complexité voilà tu nous av envoyé sur
les les élection la période électorale
Oni tout de suite parce que
ex ta gueule c'est un programme
politique donc dans ce temps fort
politique de des mois qui précèdent
l'élection présidentiell c'est dommage
ce soit juste quelques mois tous les 5
ans mais évidemment qu'on est qu'on se
sent impliqué
interrogéon réagit quotidiennement tout
ce qu' peut se dire puisqueeffectivement
enfin on parle un peu
politique mêsune des parités du
programme aussi c'est qu'on fait pas
d'actu or il se trouve que
systématiquement la nous rattrape et
l'exemple type c'est que on a décidé de
faire un épisode sur l'assistana
systèmes sont d'actu he voilà évidemment
le système est toujours d'ctu par
définition systèmes et les systèmes en
l'occurrence tous ceux qui ont des
cortiques et la sistana on a défini il y
a très longtemps avant que ça monte
évidemment que ça soit encore pire et
moi sincèrement je le dis sans sans
fausse pudeur moi j'ai chialé en lisant
certains trucs que j'ai lu des rapports
mais mais vraiment mais absolument
révoltant sur la condition de certaines
personnes et la raison pour laquelle il
ne demandait pas l'humiliation
l'humiliation sociale mais la conscience
ou alors la non la conviction pardon que
tu N a pas droit à certaines choses ou
alors l'idée que si tu les demandes
alors tu es un mendiant que il y a ça et
je je ne peux pas m'empêcher de me dire
que tous ces gens qui parlent de
laassistana en mentant parce que en
l'occurrence ils le savent c'est ça la
différence entre le mensonge et l'erreur
c'est que Laurent voquier il est
président du conseil régional il sait il
a les chiffres il a été au conseil
général il a les chiffres il sait
combien on distribue il sait combien de
gens demandent et ne demandent pas la la
fraude à la carte la carte vitale et et
effectivement on voit comme ça des mots
qui sont balancés et qui créent des
mythologies intellectuelles comme
laassistana alors qu'on se rend compte
qu'en fait bah les non recours les
personnes qui ne demandent pas ce à quoi
ils ont droit couvre mais plusieurs fois
tout ce la la petite fraude de la de des
des des des revenus garantis et des de
la sécurité sociale qui elle correspond
à une fraction infiniteésimale de la
grosse fraude de aux impôts et et
notamment aux impôts sur les sur les les
activités d'entreprise et avec Julien on
se tape ça dans la gueule régulièrement
et ça nous hérisse parce que on est dans
cette profondeur là et on y est dans la
profondeur factuelle mais aussi
émotionnelle ça nous accroche c'est
c'est profondément je reviens à ce truc
d'humain parce que c'est un un late
motif permanent mais quand le revenu de
base arrive sur le je garde cet exemple
là sur la table les seules question et
on a une vraie carence journalistique
là-dessus je
trouve c'est que les seules questions
c'est combien ça va coûter et et juste
on laisse passer les les critiques qui
disent c'est la fin du travail mais
personne pas un journaliste sur aucun
débat va dire mais attendez du coup ça
veut dire que quoi est-ce que tout le
monde accrédite en fait sans poser de
question l'idée que le revenu universel
ça serait toucher de l'argent à rien
[__] mais c'est d'une bêtise infinie
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas qui s'est
pas posé 2 secondes pour réfléchir à
quoi ça va servir si vous discutez avec
n'importe qui qui porte cette question
là tout le monde va vous expliquer que
c'est là notamment que ça libère du
temps pour créer des choses pour
fabriquer pour traver TR un peu comme
chez Google non euh sur les les jours le
le quart de le c'est quoi c'est un c'est
un jour par semaine ou ou le 5è quelque
chose comme ça ouais effectivement il
développe des trucs c'est voilà après
eux ils le développent avec une autre
logique explique explique pour les B
Google laisse alors mais je peux pas
donner de chiffre réel parce que je
connais pas mais laisse une part du
temps de ses employés pour développer
des projets totalement personnels et en
et en et complètement décorréés de leur
activité chez Google voilà ça fait
partie du contrat ils sont payés c'est
un jour payé pareil je crois que c'est
un jour par semaine où ils peuvent faire
développer le projet qu'ils veulent pour
leur propre créativité alors le revenu
de base intègre un peu cette idée là si
ce n'est que en fonction et c'est ça qui
est compliqué avec le revenu de base
encore une fois c'est un concept
complexe le revenu de base il est
défendu par les ultralibéraux comme des
gens de gauche donc il peut être
totalement destructeur d'une protection
sociale c'est vrai certains l'entendent
comme ça et il peut être en même temps
complètement porteur d'une solidarité
complètement nouvelle et contributive et
ouvrir à d'autres choses mais pour ça
faut juste à un moment donné accepter
une forme de complexité du monde quoi et
c'est pareil avec les questions
climatiques où on enfin pendant le débat
on a renvoyé sans à la dette il y a eu
cette phrase qui depis jadas qui moi m'a
fait hurler à savoir avec vous c'est
fromages ou dessert c'estuit de saon
[__] non mais avec vous c'est fromag
dessert mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas
dire com c'est ah bah quoi vous dites
que ça a coûter cher d'éviter à nos
enfants d'avoir des cancers à cause de
la pollution dieszel écoutez franchement
là j'hésite quoi je suis un peu ça a
coûter cher non mais sans déconner on
est en 2017 la C21 il en a fait des
caisses et maintenant il nous raconte ça
et et une demi-heure plus tard il dit
l'état d'urgence on va peut-être pas en
parler c'est un sujet un peu technique
sans déconner det c'est quoi c'est une
basse blue non mais faut faut arrêter le
délire quoi donc l'état d'urgence c'est
un peu technique parce qu'en gros ôter
des libertés bon c'est on veut pas trop
en parler par contre il faut savoir
enfin supprimer un maximum de postes de
fonctionnairees ça c'est un truc on veut
en parler beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et à aucun moment c'était
l'expression de je sais plus le le l'un
des merde un économiste atterré qui
disait vous vous rendez compte que vous
avez un débat aujourd'hui où les gens
c'est des économistes qui parlent
d'économie c'est des économistes qui ont
eu un AVC ils ne voi plus que la colonne
des dépenses fréri le c'est leord Don
exactement voilà ils sonti ils ne voi
plus que la colonne des dépenses ils ont
oublié que bah parfois en donnant de
l'argent à certaines choses et ben on en
retirait un bénéfice alors c'est pas un
bénéfice avec des euros avec un chiffre
d'affaires avec de la croissance et ce
genre de de My de mythologie ou de des
systèmes comptables c'est du bénéfice
humain social un intérêt social et ça
l'intérêt social ouais il nous reste 15
minutes ensemble ça passe vite donc on
va vous poser des questions un peu
chiantes maintenant Henry oui comment tu
vois l'avenir rose par
Rose raconte un peu on vous laisse j'ai
un choix à faire vous avez la même
question après rassurez-vous com je vois
l'avenir sincèrement en fait intérêt que
ce soit sincère tu es
surit a un débat entre moi et moi là qui
se passe dans ma petite tête il y a une
part de moi qui a envie de dire et qui
écoute il y a pas de raison que ça se
passe mal puisqu'il suffit que
qu'on fasse que tout le monde fasse des
choses d'une manière ou d'une autre dans
un sens plutôt positif et voilà ça peut
voilà cette partie là cette cette cette
dimension optimiste dans ma tête est
rapidement calmée
parens un peu plus réaliste je crois que
dès lors que d lors qu'on observe le
monde sujet par sujet thématique par
thématique tranche par tranche
l'impression quand même que tous les
voyants sont au rouge que le cynisme que
l'obsession de l'argent que la logique
de que le commerce que le rapport de
force qu'unile
commerce nous met nous humains dans une
situation impossible et que ce sont des
tendances très fortes qu' va
falloir vraiment faire beaucoup pour
inverser cette tendance qui nous mène
dans le mur qui est uneance très morbide
ce que moi ce qui me fascine dans la
logique dans les logiques commerciales
je sais pas comment intituler
capitaliste mais bonil en tout cas
celles qui qui qui sont obsédé par les
colonnes de dépenses et de profit euh
c'est c'est que c'est morbide c'est que
ça crée de la mort quoi fondamentalement
ça crée de la mort quelque sujet que ce
soit là récemment étions sur le sur le
l'agriculture
industrielle industrielle bah ça tue les
sols ça tue les gens avec les pesticides
ça tue les premiers ça tue les paysans
leurs enfants et voilà donc qu comm nous
sommes dans les tendances morbides on
peut difficilement être optimiste même
question
euh moi je suis d'un naturel plutôt
optimiste donc je reste optimiste après
diversité comment je vois ouais
exactement après comment je vois le
futur en fait je le vois surtout au
présent donc je je je m'intéresse
surtout au présent et au passé et
j'essaie de pas trop m'interroger trop
loin sur le futur euh j'essaie juste de
faire rencontrer le présent et le passé
pour on verra ce qui se passe mais euh
ce qui est sûr c'est que le futur en
tout cas si on veut sortir un peu de ces
histoires là c'est c'est sûr que ça va
être un futur un peu en lutte et
pourtant je suis pas un un militant
point levé du tout mais je pense qu'il y
a des des des luttes de moi je les vois
de alors c'est encore une fois c'est un
point de vu très individuel à
l'intérieur du du trio moi je les vois
comme des luttes de pensé en fait
c'estàdire de de comment on pense le
monde et et je m'en rends compte parce
que je vois des penseurs je pense à un
Bernard stigler par exemple qui me
fascine parce que quand parce que c'est
un philosophe et que quand il définit
des mots et des concepts je vois un
boxeur en fait je vois un boxeur qui qui
veut s'en plafonner la silicone vallée
qui veut s'en plafonner le
transhumanisme qui veut s'en plafonner
des concepts qui trouvent dangereux pour
l'avenir de la société pour ce qui
créent parce que ces concepts là ont des
répercussions concrètes dans des actions
d'entreprise dans des actions de de soci
de de de de voilà qui touche la société
et et je pense que la période dans
laquelle on est est fascinante pour ça
parce que il y a des choses qui émerge
de ça en fait c'est-à-dire que il y a
une il y a il y a un combat de pensée
euh qui est qui est assez enthousiasment
parce qu'il y a des il y a des voilà il
y a des choses qui émergent on a des on
a des des des complexités à laquelle il
faut faire arriver à faire face et euh
il faut sacrément se creuser le la tête
pour arriver à trouver des choses qui
vont permettre de de faire en sorte que
que ça soit vivable pour tout le monde
et ce qui est passionnant c'est que je
sens qu'il y a plein de gens qui
réfléchissent à ça en fait c'estàd que
c'est pas des petits cénacles fermés il
y a une pensée ouverte très forte très
partagé
très passionné qui part dans voilà qui
des fois se contredit qui des fois s'en
plafon mais c'est pas un problème mais
il y a un truc voilà très très fort au
cœur duquel nous on s'imerge tout le
temps et c'est pour ça que c'est si
juste d'être présent sur Youtube et
d'être présent sur les réseaux
numériques de manière générale parce que
voilà cette agitation elle traverse tout
ça il y a pas de à toi
euh alors moi pour aller un peu dans la
continuité de Julien j'ai j'ai eu ces
derniers temps quelques épiphanies
notamment par rapport à l'éducation
populaire et je pense que on a on est
dans cette démarche là aussi avec dat
taagule j'étais émerveillé l'éducation
populaire un peu comme mich michelfy ou
non mais parce qu'on est en janvier tu
parles deépiphanie mais voilà
effectivement on n pas tiré les droits
et on les a décapité et
donc l'éducation populaire alors raconte
c'est dans c'est dans cette démarche
c'est en fait pour moi il a il y a cette
notion à laquelle j'espère d' taagule
participe et et je l'ai pe je l'ai vu
participer parce que on fait des Pres on
invit à des conférences et en soit je je
m'en bats les couilles de de d'aller
faire notre pub ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de rencontrer les personnes qui nous
regardent et de comprendre pourquoi
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça leur fait
dans leur tête et dans leur vie et ce
qui est formidable c'est que tu lèves de
l'enthousiasme avec ça juste en faisant
notre taf de journaliste en faisant
notre taf de de Réal en faisant notre
taf d'auteur on lève de l'enthousiasme
et c'est un enthousiasme qui est
agissant donc ça pousse des gens à agir
et à y a il y a quelques temps j'aurais
probablement été dans dans un pessimisme
proche de celui d'Henry et il m c'est
pas toujours je sais je sais dans la
moitié dans l'hémisphère droit dans
l'hémisphère droit de d'Henry dans
l'hémisphère pessimiste mais en fait
j'ai j'ai conscience des enjeux et j'ai
d'autant plus conscience des enjeux que
comme je m'occupe de l'enquête je me
baffre des trucs extrêmement négatifs et
que après avec Julien il m'apporte
encore plus de trucs négatif mais j'ai
conscience des enjeux par contre j'ai
aussi cette conscience Julien parlait de
lutte pour moi la lutte elle est
culturelle je j'ai j'ai j'ai pris j'ai
pris une claque dans la gueule en
découvrant les réflexions de gramchi sur
finalement le fait que si tu veux
émanciper des gens émanciper pas dans le
sens leur dire quoi penser à la place de
ce qu'il pensent parce qu'ils pensent
mal non leur apprendre à faire émerger
en eux-mêmes la conscience de leur
pouvoir d'agir et d'agir pour leur
propre bien mais qui sera un bien commun
et là-dedans les réflexionsour de la
démocratie aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est le meilleur moment avec son
présidentiel pour se battre les couilles
de la démocratie institutionnelle
c'estàd que je pense que le meilleur
moment là pour justement se dire bah
plutôt que d'aller V pour un mec qu'on
va jamais croiser qui va jamais te
consulter te demander ton avis c'est le
meilleur moment pour aller dans des
quartiers avec des gens qui qu'on
ninterroge jamais à qui on parle jamais
auquel on demande jamais ce qu'il pense
dans des zones rurales dans des bassins
ouvriers dans des zones isolées et
cetera et leur demander juste le avis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et comment on
peut vous aider à le faire et ça je
trouve ça extraordinaire il y a des gens
des un collectif comme passant nous qui
essaie de créer à côté de de la
démocratie institutionnelle une
démocratie d'interpellation d'action ça
ça me fascine et je suis positif et
optimiste dans la mesure où je vois
là-dedans un esprit d'Internet mais sur
le terrain aussi internet c'est très
bien pour s'organiser mais il y a un
moment où il faut se voir et se voir
aujourd'hui c'est à mon sens le truc le
plus révolutionnaire que tu puisses
faire c'est te [__] autour d'une table
avec des gens que tu connais ou pas et
leur dire c'est quoi notre problème
commun et comment on peut le résoudre
ensemble et ça cette notion de
collaboration et de faire émerger les
solutions les problèmes puis les
solutions ensemble je trouve ça
tellement riche et tellement fort sais
tu sais comment on appelle ça chez les
hackers quand on se retrouve en physique
de quoi les le meet space le l'espace
l'espaceace ouais ouais ouais tout à
fait d'être d'être IRL bah voilà tu vois
de créer des des des des des des jury
participatifs de créer de de l'action de
faire du community organizing alors TR
trois petites questions encore
l'autocensure chez les journalistes
est-ce qu'il y a de l'autocensure chez
vous comment on ferait pour améliorer la
profession de
journaliste petite question tranquille
minut c'est la faute du caméraman
réalisateur derrière moi là non mais
pour le coup l'autocensure de mon point
de vue c'est le problème de la presse
avant tout pour avoir été dans les
rédactions et avoir beaucoup de
confrères avec qui j'échange le coup de
monsieur d'assaau qui passe un coup de
téléphone et qui dit vous pouvez me
corriger le trisème paragraphe sur la
deème page parce que ça me plaît pas ça
c'est marginal c'est ultra marginal la
plupart du temps c'est un journaliste
qui a peur d'être
sa
s et la pire et la pire des autocensures
la pire des autocensures c'est vous
allez voir David Pujadas ou Jean-Michel
ATI et vous lui dites mais David
Jean-Michel la dette c'est pas si grave
c'est pas si grave que ça il y a
d'autres problèmes à côté il vous
regardent dans les yeux vous disent mais
bien sûr que si c'est le plus grave des
trucs qui arrivve en France aujourd'hui
et là tu dis mais [__] la COP 21 la
pauvreté les le développement de
certaines maladies lié au perturbat
endocrinien tout ça et non ils en sont
persuadés et pour moi c'est ça le pire
c'est que que tu as des GES qui
finissent par être tellement enferrés
dans ça dans cette censure qu'il
finissent par y croire et là c'est ils
sont convaincus il y a une
conviction ouais ouais ouais ouais une
conviction profonde c'est ça le problème
ce qui est important une idéologie là
eux ils sont dogmatiques voilà là il y a
du dogmatisme voilà faut faut
revaloriser un peu le questionnement le
doute le ratage le truc de se dire on
peut se planter dans une interview poser
la mauvaise question pas avir interroger
ce queon croit savoir et le font jamais
ça tempsité ATT pas de nulle part enfin
je veux dire ce truc c'est pas parce que
ils sont on a pu être confronté au même
problèm au même logique Mo il a un truc
sur lequel j'ai j'ai refusé dans lequel
j'ai eu du mal à rentrer et ce qui fait
que j'en suis sorti quand j'ai pu bosser
sur des médias comme France intire et
cetera c'est l'urgence permanente du de
la quotidienne en fait et cette urgence
permanente moi enfin je sais que moi
j'arrive pas à la gérer je peux pas je
peux pas accepter des boulots comme ça
parce que ça me laisse pas le temps de
penser le le sujet que je traite en fait
donc nécessairement un enfin logiquement
mécaniquement tu finis par aller vers
des le plus simple le plus raccourci le
plus rabattu le plus Rabé et le truc et
et voilà à un moment donné c'est naturel
de poser ces questions là sans sans
aller plus loin parce que juste tu as
pas le temps d'aller plus loin en fait
et et et je trouve que ce dont on aurait
besoin c'est de libérer un peu ce
tempslà d'ouvrir de l'espace-temps et de
voilà de de du du du temps de réflexion
tu veux rajouter un non je peux passer
la main les cheveux aucune raison mais
mais c'est un truc qui qui qui est
arrivé moi ça me reste gravé on a fait
une projection pour le 82 minutes le le
documentaire de 82 minutes qu'on a fait
on a fait une projection place de la
République de plusieurs n à gueule et on
a discuté toute la journée avec des gens
qui étaient là qui regardaient les
épisodes et puis qui on discutait
c'était fascinant comme discussion g et
parmi ces discussion et donner la parole
aux citoyens voilà et parmi ces
discussions là à un moment donné je
discutais avec deux jeunes qui étaient
étudiants en
sociaux on discutait on se disait mais
c'est quand même dingue là alors ce
problème là écologique machin oui mais
alors comment on arrive à trouver les
solutions mais mais on comprend en même
temps on est obligé de partir à
rendez-vous on n pas le temps en fait en
fait ça voudrait dire que si on veut
faire évoluer la société il faut qu'on
arrive à libérer du temps pour penser
revenu de base non mais c'est et là ils
m'ont dit ça et je me suis dit mais en
fait c'est évident en fait comment on
peut faire bouger une société comment on
peut demander à des électeurs d'être
avertis et de de s'investir dans la
démocratie si on leur fout des journées
là on est le passeport pour le slogan
idéologique pur hein le simple court
passeport pour le slogan idéologique pur
le simple
c'est Frédéric lordordon qui dit ça ah
oui oui mais mais ça c'est l'opposé deou
tu me sauves dernière question il nous
tu es tu es 13 à la Bour toi ou je sais
pas à quelle heure il est j'ai il est 4h
ouis
18h58 il est il est 58 de vas-y vasyy
bon
ou ça c'est notre dernière question
c'est ce qu'on ce qu'on dire de
l'émission après vous arrêtez c'est fini
bah ça dépend si c'est une bonne réponse
on pourra peut-être te reposer d'autres
questions c'est une bouteille à la mer
qu'on laisse sur Internet c'est un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
c'està-dire que autant un diplomate
qu'un chef d'entreprise ou quoi que ce
soit un journaliste il a la même
question à la fin laisser une bouteille
à la mer pour les jeunes générations sur
internet je vous écoute hen je commence
toujours je finirai cette fois-ci
commence d'accord j'ai déjà commencé moi
doncout à la
mer
il faut assumer la complexité je crois
je crois que c'est ça faut pas avoir
enfin moi ce que j'aurais tendance à
dire aux jeunes génération c'est que
c'est compli c'est pas compliqué mais
c'est complexe ce qui veut dire que
c'est pas compliqué mais c'est plein de
petits mécanismes simples et qu'il faut
prendre le temps de les ouvrir et ça
peut même être fun c'est c'est comme des
petits trucs qu'on nous ah c'est marrant
tu fais ça voilà faut avoir faut prendre
ce plaisir là faut prendre le plaisir de
la complexité je crois que c'est un truc
qu'il faut assumer et et apprendre si on
peut la prendre dès le plus jeune âge
c'est cool en fait ça nous aide h moi je
dirais euh il y a rien de ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui de positif dans notre
société tout ça qui né à une époque
était considéré comme impossible donc
c'est la fameuse la fameuse expression
comment est-ce qu'on mange un éléphant
une cuillère à la fois et s'informer les
végétarien en l'occurrence euh
s'informer informer les autres débattre
et faire jaillir les solutions de nos
contradictions mais le faire ensemble ne
pas rester dans son coin je pense que la
tentation d'internet c'est la tentation
de se dire que à soi seul on aura la
sagesse la tentation j'ai pas dit le la
la tentation d'internet d'innet c'est se
dire je peux acquérir cette sagesse par
moi-même il y a des outils pour acquérir
une partie de la sagesse mais la sagesse
n'existe qu'ensemble et
ensemble il y a tout ce qu'on a
construit de positif dans cette société
on la construit ensemble il y a pas un
mec tout seul qui a changé sa qu' dis
ensemble tout est possible déjà je sais
pas mais
mais seul seul on va on va plus vite
mais ensemble on va plus
loin ça
c'est malien je suis pour rien merde je
rajouterai juste à la complexité c'est
que la complexité elle entraîne la
nuance et voilà c'est essentiel en fait
Panton moi ma petite bouteille en fait
je prolonge en fait la l'heure parce
qu'on finalement on est on est ensemble
sur ta gueule pas pour rien complètement
donc
oui bien sûr VI la complexité aimer la
complexité se méfier des bonimenteurs et
des réponses faciles se méfier des
dogmes se méfier des gens qui qui qui
savent à notre place qui prépensent le
monde à notre place pour pour pour
penser le monde il faut d'abord
l'éprouver aller croiser les gens
croiser les autres aller ailleurs
apprécier l'altérité ce qui nous ce qui
nous bouleverse nous transforme nous
change parce que c'est parce que parce
que c'est parce que c'est différent et
l'al
qui est plus vaste que la différence
différence notion un peu un peu étroite
finalement l'altérité c'est vraiment
tout ce qui nous rempli d'autre chose
heureusement puisque puisque seul on
n'est pas on n pas très intéressant tout
seul dans son coin voil c'est la
multitude
ouais pour notre communauté pour résumer
un peu tout ça on partage de temps en
temps un slogan publicitaire d'une
compagnie de bus qui dit c'est plus
intelligent de voyager en groupe on on
vous conseille d'aller voir ce truc là
ça décrit parfaitement ce que vous venez
de nous décrire vous voulez rajouter
quelque chose je remercie bah merci
c'est
derrière alors vous avez une question à
nous poser euh vous faites ça pourquoi
vous faites ça en fait ça sert à quoi
tout ça pourquoi des caméras pourquoi
des des questions la présence de
morordine derrière c'est
obligatoire
derrière pourquoi on fait ça
euh parce que on en avait assez de voir
émerger des des nouveaux gourous sur
Internet tant les anciens qui étaient
pour nous qui sont pour nous les
journalistes ou les nouveaux gourous qui
ont émergé avec la crise financière des
gens qui sont emparés un petit peu de
notre Internet et on avait décidé de bah
de sortir pour montrer que on pouvait
faire des choses simples avec très peu
de Mo et poser les questions en direct
aux gens pour aborder le sujet en face à
face à la loyale et on a décidé de le
faire pour le bien commun de l'Internet
et c'est qui la personne que vous
aimeriez avoir le plus et que pour
l'instant
vous alors le là o on s'est pris des
vestes on va vous on va tout vous
raconter les gars alors on a pris des
vestes avec l'ambassadrice américaine en
France chante chante rien perdu comme on
est des petits malins on s'est et on a
un petit peu travaillé au corps leur
standardiste qui est d'ailleurs très
charmante très poli qui parle un
français parfait qui nous a expliqué que
madame l'ambassadice avait des notions
de français limité qu'elle ne pourrait
pas subir une interview de 1 heure face
à une chaîne Youtube de hackur très
sourcé non Moné sur qui non monté
exactement et surtout on donne pas les
questions à l'avance bon faut dire qu'on
les a même pas nous-même donc ça
vachement donc ça la première veste
c'est celle-ci l'ambassade de Chine on a
pas de
nouvell le site le site Internet de
l'ambassade de Chine est à la la hauteur
de leur envie de communiquer avec nous
Français c'est-à-dire à l'abandon tuas
un cœur face
à compqué ouais et puis non bah c'est
les seules vestes qu'on s'est tapé si il
y a Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui nous fait
traîner un petit peu depuis 4 mois et
demi mais les gens que tu aimerais vous
rencontrer toi que que tuim intervie que
vous là intervie
aussi on se se refuse rien
en fait on peut avoir pratiquement qui
on veut mais c'est bien c'est vivant
tout ça le
le on se donne toujours les moyens de
saisir ce qu'on veut c'est quoi votre
vision du futur on avait dit une
question les gars mais on est tro une
question chacun notre vision du futur
moyen terme long terme c'est vous plat
on va essayer de résumer ça ils me
prennent tous les tous nos voyants
toutes nos sondes sociétales sont au à
l'écarlate la soutenab sociétale sur les
ressources sur l'augmentation des
violences sur l'incapacité des États à
communiquer d'une façon diplomatique
ouverte donc c'est compliqué sur cette
partie là on voit comme vous l'émergence
de nouveaux phénomènes collaboratif
qu'on essaie soit de pousser soit
d'éclairer soit de
baquer avec nos petits moyens mais on a
quand même la puissance de l'Internet
avec nous donc ça ça nous ça nous
rassure je pars sous sous votre contrôle
les gars
et et comment on voit le futur dur
euh nous on est un petit peu des
passagers clandestins parce qu'on est
très privilégié on a une situation
professionnelle qui connaît pas encore
la crise et c'est pour ça qu'on fait ça
bénévolement mais le futur va
être tendu faut un nouvel internet pour
le futur il a un nouvel internet ça veut
dire quoi bah est-ce qu'il faut
transformer est-ce qu' s'est transformé
est-ce qu'il faut le transformer tu dis
heureusement on a Internet est-ce que
est-ce qu'on aura temp trans peutêtre la
question c'est plus le web mais
peut-être libérer des l'interconnexion
des réseaux lours c'est nous nous on le
fait tous les jours on a on a des des
réseaux très
transverses donc on arrive à voir qui on
veut pour discuter du futur de l'avenir
et des conseils pour les jeunes
générationson vous avez fini de nous
cuisiner d'accord on fera une émission
si vous voulez une prochaine fois en
tous les cas merci d'être venu nous voir
merci à vous vous avez été parfait de A
à Z ça s goupié du d'une façon parfaite
des communications rapides comme on aime
c'estàd tout le monde dans tout le monde
dans une même boucle c'était super sympa
au nom de l'équipe merci c'était cool de
voci cool
[Musique]
merci avec un truc il contredit mais il
faut l'assumer et quand est-ce que le 2
secondes excuse-moi par qu'on a un souci
de son ça frotte ici c'est ça ça frotte
ici norm frotte il faut le sortir un
tout petit peu faut pas qu'il soit en
contact avec ta chemise il était en
contact avec ta chemise c'est bon c'est
bon
je voulais intervenir ça frotte ici ou
puis glisser tes mains dans mon corsage
on
connaasion mais vous le couperez au
montage de toute façon Glob fait pas de
montage il y a pas de
montage c'est bon on est bon là je suis
désolé pour la communauté il y a des
petits bruits des frottements il n pas
en contact
[Musique]
étonnment alors
attends al est-ce que tu veux qu'on
continue pendant ce temp ouis je
commencais à avoir une petite érection
donc ça tombait bien c'est le Pit
Stop ouais alors ça se passe
bien donc pendant que pendant qu'on
traistement ça pour êre total direct
pendant qu'on trafistole la magie de
l'cut ouais on vous êtes déjà ça vous
est déjà arrivé de vous faire fa checker
par l'Internet d'une façon violente une
fois récemment façon violente il y a un
petit truc quand même du côté de
d'ortibiologie ouais ouais il y a il y a
eu des ouais il y a des vérifications
sur les sources des gens qui sont pas
d'accord effectivement il y a eu un truc
atts c'était sur quoi sur pharmae la
pharmae ah oui sur les pharmindustrie
pharmaceutique
ex Il a reproché des billets
effectivement j'ai une réponse de
Candide que je vais faire sur cette
question là
pardon et après vous la préciserez vous
la nuancerez on va la
nuancer peut-être que vous allez nous
autoriser à faire un semi
coupure ser
moife éviter
ça c'est
super ça c'est les al du
direct
doncuc
de Ré on recalme on se
calmeends pas compte le niveau de
calmitude tu peux te remettre en
position comme là là il est en train de
nous faire un contest là
ok
prêt c'est toi qui relance allez c'est
parti donc on en était à le fact
[Musique]
checking